[Musica]
un pomeriggio
io sono un medico mi occupo di
nefrologia le malattie dei reni magari
vediamo insieme più avanti anche questo
tema però volevo raccontarvi iniziare
sul parquet io ho voluto fare il medico
perché per me era importante riuscire
fin da piccolo riuscire a comprendere le
varie sfaccettature della vita
sì da parte organiche le malattie ma
anche da quella psicologica gli aspetti
emozionali le culture arrivo da una
famiglia in cui i miei non mi avevano
fatto la guerra
nemmeno raccontato volto di questi
aspetti quindi uscire comprendere come
sia possibile che l'uomo arrivasse a
certe situazioni permesso imprestata una
cosa importante e quindi io la guerra
non l'ho vissuta qua io ho pensato che
fosse utile fare delle esperienze in
paese in via di sviluppo in paesi in
guerra per comprendere le culture le
religioni locali come l'uomo interagisce
l'un l'altro perché la dinamica dei
gruppi è qualcosa che condiziona la
società ovviamente no questa slider non
sono io quello dell'immagine retro i
capelli però rappresenta il percorso che
io ho dentro di me come percezione
necessario per comprendere l'indole
umano un percorso difficile cupo ombroso
era
però mio nonno mi diceva sempre il nonno
che ha fatto la guerra quando dovrai
fare una scelta sceglie sempre la strada
più difficile ma è quella più facile e
per scegliere una strada difficile come
questa scalinata vuole coraggio
ovviamente ma ci vuole anche curiosità
determinazione ma anche una certa dose
di incoscienza e quindi per raggiungere
quell'obiettivo
magari insieme adesso cerchiamo di
capire alcuni passaggi
qua siamo a giacarta e una
manifestazione pacifica si trasforma
incomprensibilmente in una rissa
collettiva
i gruppi sono complesse le dinamiche dei
le persone all'interno di cruz che sono
complessi e creano delle situazioni
imprevedibili e spesso non replicabili e
soprattutto le dinamiche e le azioni dei
singoli membri all'interno del gruppo
non corrispondono quasi mai alle azioni
e le dinamiche del gruppo ognuno ognuno
di noi da solo si comporterebbe in
maniera diversa rispetto a come si
comporta in gruppo e certe volte in
maniera opposta a quello che si comporta
il gruppo e questo crea una difficoltà
enorme nell'aspetto scientifico che
necessita la replicabilità e quindi non
usciamo a comprendere completamente
quali siano le dinamiche dei gruppi ci
sono stati alcuni esperimenti sociali
questo è un esperimento di ash qual è la
linea
4 ovviamente bene se io prendo questa
immagine
la metto in una classe ea destro tutti i
partecipanti alla classe di dire che la
linea più lunga è la seconda la terza la
seconda ok e poi chiamò una persona
ignara vittima dell'esperimento e
cominciamo a chiedere a tutti quanti
quali è la linea più lunghe tutti
rispondono ovviamente la 2 arriva il suo
turno
lui risponde nel 75 per cento delle
volte le sponde da due quindi solo il 25
per cento di voi i 25 persone su 100
avrebbero il coraggio di uscire dalle
dinamiche del gruppo su uscendo dal
centro rosso uscire dalle dinamiche del
gruppo perché questo perché noi abbiamo
bisogno di essere accettati dal gruppo
perché accettate dal gruppo vuol dire
essere protetti
gli abbiamo bisogno di protezione di una
zona di comfort e quindi nel 75 per
cento delle volte scegliamo la strada
più facile non quella più difficile
come diceva il mio nonno questo cosa ci
comporta ci comporta il fatto che non
siamo più liberi di pensare che non
riusciamo ad emanciparsi
tutti parliamo di emancipazione
femminile eccetera eccetera
emancipazione delle persone
emancipazione vuol dire essere libere
dalle costrizioni di pensiero
il 75 per cento di noi non è manci fatto
questo è il problema e quindi cosa
succede diventiamo vittime del potere
delle autorità dei media e diventiamo
pedine pedine quindi non più attori
della nostra vita e quindi frustrati
perché chi fa una vita che non è la
propria diventa il frustrato non è
contento
insoddisfatto della vita e questo crea
un enorme problema nella società e
quindi nei gruppi e allora facendo tutte
queste mie sperimentazioni mentali anche
sociali
ho cercato di pensare quale luogo
migliore per provare a vedere se ci sono
tre strade per rendere noi stessi più
gratificati da quello che facciamo e
nell'ambiente lavorativo è il posto
migliore noi basiamo tutta la nostra
vita sostanzialmente nel lavoro famiglia
e lavoro
se guardiamo le ora siamo più al lavoro
che in famiglia e quindi nelle mie
analisi ho cercato di capire quali
fossero i pilastri le dinamiche migliori
per raggiungere uno stato di
gratificazione nell'ambito lavorativo e
mi sono imbattuto in questo
impronunciabile vero geek sacmi aie e il
nome di uno psicologo
questo è il nome di uno psicologo ed è
uno dei più importanti psicologi
nell'ambito della felicità e ungherese
naturalizzato americano è ateo rizzato
lo stato di flow cioè il coinvolgimento
emotivo massimale la trance agonistica
tutti voi in qualche maniera qualche
volta nella vostra vita
siete stati immersi in qualche cosa
tanto che nessuna cosa vi poteva
distrarla
sì o no avrete avuto qualche volta una
esperienza di questo tipo ma carini
giochi quello
e la trance agonistica il momento in cui
tutti noi dovremmo arrivare per essere
imbattibili ma non solo per fare
coincidere
l'obiettivo personale con quello del
gruppo perché noi raggiungiamo lo stato
di flow quando il nostro gruppo grazie a
noi e raggiunge la massima performance
quindi dobbiamo fare in modo che il
nostro obiettivo sia allo stesso del
gruppo e per far questo ci sono quattro
pilastri far questo vuol dire arrivare a
floro che in questo caso è rappresentato
da fiore di loto il fiore di loto lo
conoscete l'avete mai visto un fiore
splendido bellissimo che nasce su gli
stagni sulle bozze pu tre dei sull'acqua
di spagna ante e la rappresentazione
ideale dell'essere umano che fa le cose
più orrende al mondo distrugge tutto
quello che può trovare poi crea le
sinfonie di beethoven crea l'arte più
incredibile non solo la tecnologia che
ci pensa di viaggiare nello spazio
però contemporaneamente tutto questo
nasce su una situazione tremenda se ci
pensate guerra interessi personali
violazione dei diritti umani
bene il primo pilastro e bill haas hotel
il vuol dire colore verde acqua da
foglie del tè ed è stata teorizzata da
fredrik la loro è un concetto di
organizzazione aziendale in cui il
meccanismo non è verticale ma
orizzontale noi non c'è un capo che
comanda ma un insieme di gruppetti di
persone che decidono autonomamente
alcuni passaggi per rendere al massimo
la produzione e la qualità di vita entra
nell'azienda tanto che è paragonabile un
sistema quasi vivente in quei gruppetti
sono le cellule e il sistema aziendale
pil
si muove non core business plan è un
obiettivo ma si muove con la crescita di
questi gruppi che poi portano
all'obiettivo che magari è diverso da
quello iniziale
sembrano le cose utopica vero pesanti se
possibile michelin decathlon patagonia
erano le division sullo tutta
organizzazione tel
le persone all'interno
dell'organizzazione del vero sistematela
addirittura scelgono lo stipendio a
seconda di quanto hanno prodotto nel
mese in cui corrisponde allo stipendio
tanto sono responsabilizzati tanto è
diffusa la responsabilizzazione del
sistema ma per essere veramente till
bisogna saper comunicare
secondo pilastro comunicare vuol dire sì
ovviamente essere trasparenti dirci
tutto comunicare gli obiettivi
ma non è solo questo esiste una teoria
psicologica che il sistema
dell'anagramma non so se l'avete mai
sentito in cui divide la tipologia delle
persone in tre tipi diversi istintuali
emotivi e razionale le persone
all'interno di questi gruppi
quando si parlano della stessa lingua
ovviamente non percepiscono esattamente
le stesse sfumature e spesso nascono le
incomprensioni
se io dico io sono un istintuale per me
amare una persona vuol dire fare in modo
di metterla vicino a me sia un problema
e di combattere insieme per risolvere il
suo problema insieme a lei
ok questo per me vuol dire amare
razionale mare vuol dire ti stimo ma ti
stimo talmente tanto per un emotivo
invece è la spesso più romantico del
fiore non è che
le persone vogliono dire qualcosa di
diverso in fondo è la stessa cosa ma
l'interpretazione diversa
bene quindi se io conosco come e
soprattutto nei concetti astratti
i tre le tre personalità si parlano e si
interpretano allora a questo punto io
sono in grado di riuscire a comunicare
molto meglio il sistema e poi abbiamo le
altre due due pilastri che sono anche
loro hanno delle analogie fra di loro
il primo è quello della leggerezza
leggerezza non vuol dire superficialità
la teorizzata italo calvino nelle
lezioni americane di harvard leggerezza
vuol dire che quando io vi ricordate la
scalinata iniziale quando io devo
cominciare a fare quella scalinata
ombrosa tenebrosa difficile lunga
faticosa
non posso partire con uno zaino
completamente pieno di volpe boscalino
amy ferno leggerezza vuol dire che per
qualsiasi percorso
noi dobbiamo salire con uno zaino vuoto
i primi nei primi e scrivi e poi pian
piano abbiamo tutto il tempo di
aggiungersi ostacoli e complicazioni
varie che normalmente arriveranno ma più
in alto siamo e più siamo vicini allo
stato di flow più in alto siamo sono più
vicini allo stato di influenze siamo
vicini nello stato di fu siamo
imbattibile quando voi raggiungete era
stato del flu in qualsiasi situazione
sia nessuno vi può battere ricordate per
questo gamification l'avete sentita
prima però è la metodologia migliore per
imparare lo stato di flow nella vostra
esperienza personale e voi avete avuto
tante possibilità ma nel gioco tanto è
vero che si chiama trance agonistica
inizialmente nel nel gioco
raggiungete più facilmente nel se lo
stato dei flussi quindi il gioco serve
per fare team building per conoscersi
bene per avere tutta una serie di
interazioni più vicine
nell'auto nell'ambito lavorativo ma
serve perché poi impariate cosa vuol
dire trance agonistica coinvolgimento
massivo nel gioco non raggiungete molto
più facilmente
io ho imparato lo stato di flow è stato
diffuso il gioco la trance agonistica
con la mia macchina
questo è il quadrante della mia
automobile e mi sono accorto che è per
anni miss fidava e io non capivo che
stava giocando questa linea orizzontale
identifica la parte bianca il mio
consumo io cellula l'acceleratore e
aumenta la parte bianca il rombo e la
media ogni volta che io accelero non
devo superare quel rombo altrimenti la
macchina comincia frigia b dei rumori
strani beep beep eccetera eccetera ma il
problema è che quella è una media e
quindi meno io raggiungo quel rombo come
vuole la mia macchina più quel rombo si
sposta a sinistra e quindi michela il
gioco sempre più difficile ovviamente e
quindi aumenta la difficoltà e io ogni
volta devo riuscire arrivava un punto e
qui tutti mi sul lavoro dietro perché
non vinceva sulla macchina alla fin fine
del gioco però io consumo 300 400
chilometri in meno a pieno solo facendo
giocando ogni volta su questo con questo
sistema bene perché vi sto raccontando
tutte questa cosa perché tutto questa
cosa che in poi è teorizzata tutto
sommato è stata messa in pratica in due
aspetti uno la fondazione ausilia in
dieci anni si è diffusa in tutto il
mondo e abbiamo fatto tutta una serie di
attività umanitarie artistiche culturali
che adesso non vi sto a dire per
mancanza di tempo
poi ci sono due articoli di giornale il
primo è una bambina soldato che noi
abbiamo tolto durante la guerra civile
dal carcere era una terrorista da bill
non so se voi conoscete le tigri tamil
che cosa sono via dicendo
e l'abbiamo portata a udine a riparare a
guarire su un braccio perso in battaglia
e secondo sempre durante la guerra
civile in sri lanka
abbiamo liberato 180 bambini dal carcere
minorile bambini che avevano 3 4 5 6
anni quindi si può dire che avessero
commesso un reato
queste attività sono avvenute grazie
alla forza della negoziazione di auxilia
ma imparata sul meccanismo dei quattro
pilastri perché questo perché negoziale
vuol dire fare quello che voglio io
alle vostre condizioni e quindi è molto
simile al concetto di flou in cui
l'obiettivo personale coincide con
l'obiettivo del gruppo diventiamo io e
il negoziatore è la persona che deve
negoziare con me un tutt'uno e facciamo
in modo che l'obiettivo mia come sponda
su questo e negoziazione e questo invece
è la rappresentazione dello stesso
meccanismo messo inserito all'interno di
un reparto ospedaliero il mio io sono
responsabile di questo piccolo reparto
all'ospedale di civita del friuli di
nefrologia delle malattie del rene
quindi ci riconduciamo al concetto di
prima e nel giro di questo
e scusate questo è il momento in cui
prendo in mano la questione e le
prestazioni con lo stesso personale e
con lo stesso budget
il primo anno aumentano a 14.000 e poi
arriviamo 20 3.461 praticamente più che
raddoppiate in due anni poi cisa
stabilizziamo su questo livello
puramente più di così non riusciamo a
fare però è una grossa e un grosso
risultato soprattutto perché è un ambito
pubblico dove non c'è la vendita diretta
cioè non c'è il rapporto il feedback io
vendo e quindi ho un feedback di questo
tipo è un ambiente pubblico quindi tutta
l'attività è dovuta è permessa da quei
quattro pilastri
concludo ciò ancora 11 secondi con credo
che questa slide c'è un bambino che
guarda attraverso un pertugio e
rappresenta un po la nostra infanzia
almeno sicuramente la mia io l'ho sempre
curioso di entrare dentro dentro i
luoghi bui e questo vuol dire che in
qualche maniera tutti noi dobbiamo
mantenere una parte di incoscienza di
curiosità di gioco e di leggerezza per
poter raggiungere lo stato di flow ma
soprattutto la strada difficile che noi
degli utili che prendiamo per la nostra
crescita
magari è anche molto bella e divertente
grazie a tutti